the Vietnam War ended 40 years ago on
April 30th 1975 the North Vietnamese
took over the south and reunified the
country under communism more than a
thousand Americans and nearly 6,000
Vietnamese and third country nationals
were airlifted out as many as 3.8
million Vietnamese and over 58,000 US
soldiers died during the Vietnam War in
the years that followed a mass exodus of
South Vietnamese fled the country
an estimated two million Vietnamese
eventually left many risking their lives
escaping by boat and foot they fled to
foreign countries sometimes being sent
back to Vietnam other times taken into
refugee camps and millions of Americans
and Vietnamese have died and suffered
from exposure to Agent Orange eleven
percent of veterans also suffer from
post-traumatic stress disorder the
Vietnam War may have ended in 1975 but
the impacts continue to reverberate
today
why are there so many US bases on this
island in Japan the Battle of Okinawa
was one of the bloodiest Pacific combats